سي وورلد أبو ظبي هي أكبر
حديقة ترفيهية داخلية للحياة البحرية في العالم تزيد مساحتها عن
183000 متر مربع، لذا فهي مجرد
مساحة ضخمة ولكن سيتم تغطيتها
بموائل الحيوانات من قبل الضيوف ومساحة من
المطاعم عن طريق التسوق،
ويأتي شخص ما من الضيوف لرؤية ما
أبو ظبي  أبوظبي، ستتاح لهم الفرصة
لرؤية أكثر من 150 نوعًا من
الحيوانات البحرية وما يزيد عن مائة
ألف حيوان عندما يبحثون في
الموائل المختلفة، وسيكون الكثير منها من
أنواع الأسماك لدينا، لذلك ستكون هناك
أسراب كبيرة من الأسماك وبعضها  من موائلنا الرئيسية توجد
الأسماك في كل موطن من بيئتنا
[موسيقى]
التاريخ وراء الشراكة بين
حدائق سي وورلد والترفيه في
الروح المعنوية هو إحياء عالم سي وورلد أبو ظبي،
هذا برنامج يعتمد على
أكثر من 60 عامًا من الخبرة في
تقوم حدائق Sea World بالتثقيف في مجال الحفاظ على البيئة
والتفاعل مع الضيوف وتعليمهم حقًا
عن المحيطات نفسها، مما
يجلب هذه الرؤية لما
يلزم لرعاية المحيط، ومدى
أهمية المحيط لجميع
الجوانب المختلفة للمحيط من جميع أنحاء
العالم سواء كان شيئًا ما
بداية سي وورلد أبو ظبي وهو
محيط أبو ظبي يبدأ هناك حيث
يمكنك بدء رحلتك
تكريمًا للمنطقة نفسها ولكن بعد ذلك
يمكنك السفر إلى المحيط اللامتناهي إلى
قاعدة بحرية قبالة حافة جبل بحري
[موسيقى]
و  السفر إلى العالم الاستوائي
والسفر إلى عالم القطب الشمالي لرؤية
حيوانات الفظ وثعالب البحر
أو النقطة الصخرية التي ستكون أسود
البحر وفقمات المرفأ،
كل ذلك لتثقيف الناس حول
المحيطات وتثقيف ضيوفنا ولكن أيضًا
السماح لهم بالحصول على مجرد  نقضي وقتًا رائعًا
خلال النهار
هنا في سي وورلد أبو ظبي، نحن حقًا في
الداخل، هذا عالم البحار الداخلي المكون من خمسة طوابق
وواحد من أروع
المباني التي يمكن لأي شخص أن يتخيل
تجميعها معًا ولكنها تأتي مع بعض
تلك الأشياء التي يتعين علينا القيام بها
أحد هذه الأمور هو التأكد من
حصول الحيوانات على أكبر قدر ممكن من الإضاءة الطبيعية،
لذلك قمنا بإنشاء
نظام إضاءة متطور جدًا للحيوانات
يعيد إنشاء إضاءة UVA UVB كاملة الطيف
حتى تتمكن الحيوانات من الحصول على نفس
دورات الإضاءة التي تحصل عليها بشكل طبيعي في
منزلها.  البيئة إلى جانب
مقدار المساحة التي تتمتع بها الحيوانات هي
الجيل القادم من حدائق سي وورلد التي
تمنح الضيوف فرصة لرؤية
الحيوانات التي ربما لم يروها من قبل
ومعرفة شيء عنها
لسي وورلد أبو ظبي وبعض
الضيوف المغامرين حقًا  قد ترغب في الحصول على
الفرصة التالية للقيام بالتفاعل والقيام
برحلة استكشافية، يمكنك أن تأتي وتلتقي بحيوان
الفظ عن قرب، وهو أحد أروع
الحيوانات التي ستقابلها على الإطلاق
ولكنها أيضًا كبيرة جدًا ولكننا قمنا بتصميم
الموطن الذي يمكن أن يأتي فيه الفظ
عندما  اختر التفاعل مع
بعض ضيوفنا، كن قريبًا
وشخصيًا مع الدلافين لفهم
التاريخ الطبيعي للدلافين
وما هو المهم جدًا بشأنهم والنظام
البيئي أيضًا، وستكون هناك فرص أخرى
مع أسود البحر التي تطعم أسود البحر
وبعد ذلك عندما يكون لدينا  طيور البطريق في
بيئتها، سنكون قادرين في الواقع على
إجراء تفاعلات داخل القارة القطبية الجنوبية
حيث ستكون درجة واحدة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية